yes
on Wednesday July the fourth scientists
at CERN in outside found a new particle
i watch the announcement at the Lindo
Nobel laureate meeting which this year
was dedicated to physics we have a
discovery here discovered and your
martini Rosalind possibly expose above
you have to find out which kind of
exposing business it's a great day for
Felix it's a great day for particle
physics it's a great day for CERN many
of the laureates had helped shape the
standard model what did they think about
the announcement that makes me very sad
because now there's nothing left if you
ever thought about that is the last
patch we can't go home no no no it's not
that it's plenty of thing to do they
have luminosity to be improved there is
the parentheses the machine to get fixed
there is the question of of other
phenomena which may be there and most
importantly we know now that we have
dark matter and the question is will
dark matter have to do anything the
elementary particle physics well I think
at this point we're not sure the
standard model doesn't really tell us
much about dark matter and a standard
Higgs if that was all there was we
wouldn't get any you know Inklings of
what to expect certainly my hope would
be whatever dark matter is I would love
to see that come out of the Large Hadron
Collider what they announced the
discovery of was a particle with a mass
that they have measured now too perhaps
a one or two percent accuracy but
particles have many properties they have
rotation they have spin the Higgs
particle of any kind has to have spin
zero we don't know the spin of this
particle so all of those tests are now
available and there are many many more
numbers to be measured and properties
than just the existence of a particle
Oh
hey